[Music]
okay so we're back at it again at AMC we
just got done seen the new Halloween
yeah and it looked like it was a the
executive producer I think it said was
yeah um I actually thought it was a
pretty strong entry into the Halloween
franchise I think most of them were kind
of weak beyond Halloween yeah
which actually I'm a huge fan of
Halloween 3 at Halloween 3 actually is
one of my favorite movies like well even
though it's not you know it's just a
Michael Myers but yeah it was good I
think the only complaint I had was as I
think the pacing of the edit in the
first maybe one third of the movie was
kind of slow I was getting bored some of
that I think didn't have to be in there
to make an enjoyable movie I thought
some of it was kind of like needless
background and character development and
characters that ended up being killed
off early anyway so I didn't really I
didn't really care too much for that by
the time we were about halfway through
the movie now all of a sudden I'm in the
movie I thought I was gonna see that's
the way I felt I mean yeah like it
started to feel like that it's Halloween
want and Halloween to about halfway into
it I mean that but other than that I
thought it was a pretty good movie what
did you think of it although like I said
we just recently rewatched the original
Halloween 1917
and actually to me it seemed about the
same amount of time that took character
development and everything like that it
took about the same amount of did her
stuff so I didn't really notice that
being could have written it could have
been that I was anxious to see it hey
you know that man I saw was I was
getting kind of impatient like come on
let's get that good
sometimes that's why it's good like if
you like it maybe it's better to see it
to time think it's the first time yeah I
can't really take everything in and you
can't really but I mean in general I
thought it was paced pretty much the
same as the original Halloween oh it
reminded me very much of a slasher movie
from that era like a you know not so
much in the look of it but just kind of
the pacing of it the kind of the way the
characters interacted and stuff like
that it did seem very much like the
original I really really liked most of
the characters there was like humor in
it but it wasn't overdone there was some
nice gore in it but it wasn't like a
torture boring faster I think it's a lot
courrier than the original obviously
because the original was very gory but
yeah you know they didn't go super
over-the-top with it and Jamie Lee
Curtis was great and it yeah the acting
loves her character the acting was very
it was just like it was fantastic the
look of it was great the score was great
yeah I you know they used obviously the
iconic Halloween's for but some of the
other like incidental music and stuff
like that and there was really
contributed to the overall atmosphere of
the movie we actually saw it in the big
special Dolby yes with the fat people
chairs and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so that was like actually a pretty cool
insurance because the you know the
screen was really big we're in these big
chairs when it wasn't like really loud
and so like when Michael Myers or
somebody who's like creeping her out of
the house it sounded like it was behind
you and so that was kind of cool too I
like seeing it in that environment but
like I said it's it it's really a very
worthy entering of the series there
pretty much it seemed to me there pretty
much acting like none of the movies
after Halloween too happened which Bry
was a good thing I think that was
probably the best thing to do they made
kind of like a couple little yeah mega
joke oh yes people laughs I've got the
original so yeah like big just kind of
like forgot about all the yeah which I
thought was pretty cool that was
probably the smarter is like a soft
reboot type of thing right but yeah I
actually really like there was a couple
twists in there and I wasn't really
expecting and like I said likable
characters good gore yeah it was a
strong movie that one of the better
movies of this month I would say oh yeah
and I'm definitely glad you thought I
was I actually wouldn't mind seeing it
again yeah you know just because just so
I could catch everything because it
seemed like it was a lot of stuff coming
back to me the three that stood out the
top four that really stood out this
month was for me Mission Impossible fall
out I thought that was the best one and
then underneath that would have been
house of the clock on its walls yeah
yeah vanam and then this one although I
could probably put this one I don't know
I had fun and I had fun in venom too I'd
like this better than venom but this is
more my custom or your type of dude I'm
more I'm more horror
yeah and maybe my perceptions of the
start might be slightly skewed mood has
a lot
do it the way you interfere Ruby and
maybe I was just kind of anxious for it
to start
you know I mean for the actual action to
start in the movie by the top Halloween
night rolls around I'm pretty much in
the groove I'm now in the movie that I
thought I was gonna see yeah and like I
said we watching the original Halloween
I'm like pretty much the first half of
that movie is just all character
development and you know atmosphere and
there's Michael Myers isn't really in it
they're just kind of like interaction
between all the babysitters and yeah you
know every now and then you get a
glimpse of Michael and they're like
what's that weird dude over there but
it's like they don't really do much with
it and I thought it was about the same
speaking of weird dudes we had another
weird dude in the audience always
talking to the [ __ ] screen he's by
himself I'm talking to the [ __ ]
screen this is why they want to talk to
us I'm leaving and I just looked at men
don't [ __ ] talk you know I mean
trying to make friends in movie theater
I don't know what what what this is why
I was glad that we went to the Dolby
theater because what he was talking
during the trailers and I said oh my god
yeah you talk during the whole movie I'm
gonna have to go over there and like
punch him in the face and he's
announcing spoilers and [ __ ] it's like
this reminds me and I probably mentioned
this on the podcast before he's a grunt
and there's grown man yeah it's like
going to movies old people yeah like
when you go to move in they're like
what's going on Barney sigh what it's
like that guy
I'm like dude just talking come come
into this [ __ ] it's almost like a
full-time job nowadays we're gonna see
what else is gonna happen
for the rest of this month we only got a
another week left in this month we may
have seen all the movies we really
wanted to see because I think some new
ones are probably gonna start next week
and this is decided what other ones
we're gonna see okay we're gonna see two
more for free on this weekend we've
pretty much burned them up so we're
gonna have to watch the movies we'd
already we're gonna go we're gonna go
out of our comfort sucking goosebumps or
some stupid [ __ ] small foot fall asleep
during that [ __ ] okay but yeah this is
actually a really good moving it so like
I said it seemed to be getting really
good reviews it you know it's worth
watch I would say I would put it in the
top four this month yeah definitely the
best horror movie this month oh yeah who
Hellfest away yeah I like talked about
even though I like tell us man you know
it wasn't like terrific yeah so do you
like if you like Halloween you're gonna
be you're like this one yeah
yes Jim now Jenny and I are back at it
again we're at we're at theater 14 we're
gonna see boots pop some silly ass
child's flick well we figured since it
was Halloween
there'll be a few days before Halloween
look where this comes out yeah yeah
that's like we're on this we're on this
a list program and I'll tell you what
you can watch 12 movies month so far
this month is any judge only four of
them were worth seeing yeah four of them
or worse and most of this is just kind
of we're gonna see goosebumps for some
[ __ ] reason the kids make it
hopefully it will be amusing let's see
who the [ __ ] in here oh and I also
went to the bar I asked how much one of
their [ __ ] drinks was based on the
predator they want a $13 that bucket
ring see what's going on
yeah there's one other person that's it
but yeah this is what we got is what we
got but that's a shame
let's get this kid almost
alright ok so you just got done with
goosebumps - and I think with this one
you can pretty much tell what they were
going for is kind of like a fantasy of
all like a fantasy adventure Halloween
themed movie that was kind of like fun
for the whole family
I'd probably put it there with like
gremlins and et and others feel Bergen
type [ __ ] it's about like that very
traditional it's almost got like four
additional American movie you know very
much a middle-class theme all of the
characters in the settings were kind of
almost a generic when you that that
[ __ ] but entertaining it was what
really understand like it started out
kind of here's the thing like obviously
I didn't see the first piece monster
whose most movie um the Goosebumps
series of books were very very hugely
popular in the 1930s but I was like at
that stage I was already out of high
school so I was a little older than the
age demographic my younger siblings
actually had a lot of them so I might
have read a couple of them so if you're
familiar with the book series requires
time then you will know the tone of this
because it's very much like one of his
books and actually I didn't see the
first goosebumps movie but I think I
remembered this has the return of slappy
the dummy is like one of our old signs
both families characters it also kind of
goes a little bit meta where a refers to
care is a character in the actual movie
just toward the end and it's kind of
like an unfinished manuscript send us
that's what's making all this crazy [ __ ]
happened it's essentially Halloween
coming to life yeah so there's like a
lot of you know it's very inoffensive
the kid that played Ben in Stephen
King's it last year was in it yeah
there's a couple other familiar faces
Jack Black makes an appearance yeah he's
actually has an uncredited yeah which is
actually he's been in to Halloween
movies this year already yeah you know
obviously this is not nearly as good as
house with the clock in its walls
because I have never really loved that
movie um you know but this is just
playing I'm like a fun it's it's very
tween oriented yeah we're not we weren't
the target audience for this and it's
funny because we're in there with six
other people really maybe eight I think
it probably six other people in the
audience know kids all old people I feel
like a lot of people have joined this
soap Salus thing in there so it's like
we like to make it worth it we're gonna
we have to make it three times of you
know so it's like I I actually did it by
this movie it was like it was just a fun
like oh yeah and it's like some of the
effects were pretty cool yeah the
special effects are pretty good look
they had every stereotypical Hollywood
every stereotypical Halloween monsters
in this yeah but yeah like I said I
thought that it got better as it went
along like I kind of liked the way it
ended like the you know with the yeah
they said the uncredited appearance the
RL so that first 15-20 minutes was rough
though just because everything is so
[ __ ] generic and the characters are
just so you know you know it's like very
generic very traditional stereotypical
American 2018 but just to probably go
over really well like in place like
China they probably like you love that
[ __ ] yeah it's tradition but like a real
American stuff it seems like it seems
like a cute movie to take very generic -
yeah yeah and like I said not really are
ya we're not who it's aimed at and
everybody is straight out of central
casting and everything is everything
everything is just like
unrealistic in a certain way I mean you
know
you got gay Chinese neighbors that over
decorate their there but yeah just like
it's funny [ __ ] you don't see alright
but alright yeah but that's all I'm
gonna say about it really yes we have to
think of it I can't wait to see that man
I want to see I want to see the Bohemian
Rhapsody yeah I saw the trailers that
look good all right
okay so we just got back from seeing it
was called the citrus brothers yes and
it was you know we were really scraping
the bottom of the barrel this is the
last movie that we wanted to see for
this month it was either this one or
small foot you know let's go ahead and
see the the Western so western stars and
for me you know I think Jenny and I
might differ on this movie out because I
had the feeling of Jane II enjoyed this
movie for me it was very frustrating
because the movie had many elements of a
really great Western in it it had really
an a really authentic look to it the
acting was very good Joaquin Phillips
was a walking Phoenix and everything he
came off as a very believable Old West
character there were there were many
good parts in this movie little little
story elements that were good but
imagine you take for me a great western
and strip out every story element that
makes a Western great and that's what
you have here with this movie everything
that makes it Western great was not
included in this movie I almost would
probably call this not a Western like an
anti-western there was no real clear-cut
good guys in villains everyone was kind
of night and really a villain everyone
was kind of mediocre like which you
could probably say that maybe that added
an element of realism to it but for me a
Western is almost a type of mayor
American mythology there's certain
things that have to happen in a Western
for it to be classified as a western and
sometimes this movie did it they had
some good shootouts that were kind of
believable
you know they but just all together just
the overarching story of this movie was
kind of like what's the point why am i
watching this it was kind of slow and
tedious I didn't know who to root for
what did you think of a giant you know I
had a feeling this is gonna happen but
actually I really really like this it's
a very ambiguous story
no no it's not to me I can see what
you're saying like how it's not it's not
like a standard structured Western it's
more like a drama with some dark humor
elements like set in the Old West I
thought it was like a really
straightforward story basically the
sisters brothers Charlie at Elie played
by Joaquin Phoenix and Phoenix and john
c reilly they're basically they work for
this guy called the Commodore who would
that was Rutger Hauer I'm pretty sure
and they are tasked with going to kill
this particular guy because they're
assassins for hire and then like kind of
all these strange things happen along
the trail and like all these you know
alliances you know yeah things like that
but in a way that's what I liked about
it because it gave me more of a sense of
what it might have really been like that
everyone was very morally gray like yeah
you know it's like you know even the
good guys like did terrible things and
the bad guys did good things so I kind
of liked that about it yeah it was
almost kind of gave me like an early
Walking Dead vibe yeah you know what I
mean it's that type game but funnier
okay first of all the way Ginny is
describing this movie is far better than
the actual experience of watching the
movie you're making it sound very
exciting it's not that's your opinion
though I mean I think I really liked it
a lot I was riveted I thought it was
really good I liked all the characters
okay I really liked Jake Gyllenhaal's
character and he kind of befriended the
guy that there was to kill he was played
by the same guy that doctor in venom
which I thought was very strange okay um
you know so I I don't know I just really
liked it it was almost a little bit if I
was gonna say magical realism but I
guess not really because it's kind of
like it was more kind of like a chemical
process I guess I want to say okay but
um
I actually really really liked it I can
see why audiences may not it's an indie
it's an indie movie you know it started
on the festival circuit so it's not
gonna be kind of like a crowd-pleasing
you know kind of thing like venom is or
anything like that this is kind of like
you know it's a character study
there's shootouts in it there's western
elements in it there's like a lot
there's gross [ __ ] in it you know people
get limbs cut off and things like that
but it's not like it's not an action
movie no no okay I'm gonna put it in a
way that maybe somebody who's you know
into westerns maybe though if you liked
okay my favorite Western really of all
times just was probably Unforgiven all
right if you liked Unforgiven alright
you will not like this movie most likely
it and my other one the other one I
really liked was called red Sun was from
this I think was from the 70s it had
Charles Bronson and a famous Japanese
actor whose name it eludes me right now
another one of my favorite western
movies alright if you like that movie
you won't like this one it's a very I
don't know there because I really like
I'm forgiven and I still yeah if you
expect those story elements to be in a
Western they're not in this one but like
I said I didn't really and again when we
go see movies all I knew about this one
was that it had Western elements I knew
the actors in it I knew it was based on
a novel that's pretty much all I knew
about it because I don't like to read
about movies before I go see them I like
to just kind of experience them without
any preconceptions yes so I didn't
really have any preconceptions about
what it was gonna be about I just wanted
to see what it was about so like I said
and I think I mentioned this on one of
our shows before I'm a very laid-back
movie goer I'm very willing to let the
movie take me where he wants to take me
yeah and I actually really really liked
it so you know people can differ yes out
of five stars you go to what a five star
four star um I think I'd probably give
it four it's not for everybody but I
actually really enjoyed it um I thought
the dark humor was very funny like the
acting was very good yeah um you know I
just I just liked the whole arc of the
story and like all the symbolic [ __ ]
that happened and everything
I don't know I just really liked it and
I like I said the the period detail of
like all the yeah you know the costumes
and the sets and everything like that
was amazing like all the vistas like all
the Old West and everything like that
was really cool like and but you know I
just I really liked it I figured you
probably wouldn't but I hated I hated it
give it to nine and two I'm gonna give
it a one star one star it was very
difficult for me to watch but too bad
man I think it was a missed opportunity
the movie looked great I really like the
way it looked so I guess that wraps it
up though
[Music]